we've added electrodes allowing you to
take an electrocardiogram
it's like wow they must really uh like
what we've done the
alive core was stunned because it's
accessory for Apple watch had been out
for a year before Apple's announcement
and the live course says it does almost
the exact same thing now you can take an
ECG anytime anywhere right from your
wrist a live core is one in a long list
of companies and developers I spoke with
describing similar encounters with apple
there's even a word for this it's
sherlocking often companies say they
find out they've been Sherlock twin the
rest of us find out when they're
watching Apple's big product events like
the worldwide developer conference or
WWDC in June welcome to WWDC so what
exactly is sherlocking and what happens
when these companies Sue apple and who
might be saying they're sherlocked next
back in 2002 Apple awarded an
independent app search tool called
Watson an apple design award but later
that year Apple announced an upgrade to
its existing document search tools
Sherlock it added web searching
capabilities that directly competed with
Watson but since then developers say
apple has built a reputation for
sherlocking others Apple told the
journal that it doesn't steal technology
and that it respects the intellectual
property of other companies a live
course says its chain of events unfolded
like this the company designed its heart
rhythm tracking product for Apple watch
in 2016. a year later an apple executive
reached out to talk about the
possibility of working together and they
followed up with we might try to find a
way to work with you but we might
compete with you at Apple's big Hardware
event in September 2018 it introduced
the Apple watch 4 with competing heart
tracking software and an updated
operating system my colleague Aaron
Tilley investigated Apple's patent
Behavior he says Apple also recruited a
live course employees and targeted the
company's patents and with the patent
trial the Peel Board lets them do is
they can invalidate patents of other
companies the board can review
challenged patents and determine if
they're invalid or basically if they
should have never been granted in the
first place a live chord found itself in
a years-long battle with apple a judge
ruled in 2022 that apple infringed on
its patents apple is fighting that
ruling and says many of the patent
violation claims it faces are overly
broad the company says that it will
continue to protect its Innovations and
that it was working on heart tracking
technology for the Apple watch for three
years before it launched the battle is
ongoing Apple controls multiple product
lines of devices which gives it a lot of
power through the App Store Apple can
track and learn what people want and use
that information to plan its own product
development it can also deeply link its
apps with its devices in a way that
third-party apps just can't that can
result in apps designed specifically for
Apple Hardware making the original
third-party applications seemingly less
necessary it can also offer its native
apps for no additional charge by folding
the software development costs into the
price of its Hardware this gives users
more value and reduces the need for
third-party apps Apple May save money in
the long run by developing more of its
parts in-house rather than buying or
partnering with other companies they
don't love paying a lot to buy a company
if they they don't see a point in buying
the company mostly because it's too
expensive or maybe the IP isn't directly
related to what they want they can just
hire these companies employees they they
target they can Target them recruit them
choosing not to work with apple could
mean losing out on more than 2 billion
devices around the world which is why so
many developers say they cooperate
despite knowing there's a chance they
could get sherlocked apple says all
developers can update their services to
meet its operating system requirements
if you want to play in the Apple
ecosystem you also face the potential
that Apple will become a competitor of
yours still more companies are choosing
to fight the Bluetooth tracker company
tile testified in front of Congress in
2021 alleging that Apple copied its
location tracking technology Apple says
it's competing find my network was
introduced in 2010. well before tile
launched its first product the software
developer Blix has called on others to
join in its fight against the iPhone
maker and it was a difficult choice for
us winning an extra case for a private
company is incredibly hard Blick sued
Apple claiming that the company copied
its Anonymous email sign-in tool with
sign in with apple and suppressed blix's
iPhone app and search results a federal
judge dismissed the case at the time
Apple said it acted legally by
introducing its own Innovative products
that promote competition it's very
expensive to sue Apple they fight really
hard they fight as if it's their last
fight it cost Millions for some
developers getting sherlock'd May signal
major changes ahead the startup behind
Watson stopped supporting the Mac
version in 2004. others shift their
focus to different apps and products
developers say sherlocking hurts end
users too that's because a scrappy
startup focusing on one thing may want
to provide a deeper richer experience
than you'd find elsewhere while Apple
may be more inclined to pick key
features that pair well with its other
apps and services when we talk about
antitrust this country a lot of it's
focus on consumer harm that's tricky
because it's hard to measure so who
might say they're sure locked next Aaron
reported that Apple will likely announce
a new mental health journaling app which
could easily compete with day one it
previously won an apple design award and
its founder told the journal that the
conversations with apple suddenly
stopped the co-founder of another
journaling app called Deleo says that
this move by Apple would be concerning
but it believes its users aren't going
anywhere we don't know the future I
might be like painfully mistaken then
there is wide speculation about new
hardware for developers which could
introduce an entirely new ecosystem of
ideas for Apple to draw inspiration from
the headset is kind of the main
attraction at this upcoming developer
conference they're going to be learning
about the market what the market Wants
What It needs how consumers are using
the headset it's not illegal for Apple
to cherry pick ideas that might be
similar to what developers have already
come up with and then to integrate those
features into future products but if
independent developers feel like their
ideas will just get Sherlock they may
start to get demotivated and stop
innovating
foreign foreign